why are people still buying and loving
this 2019 Intel MacBook when you can get
the 15-inch MacBook Air and how do these
two compare how much better is the new
Air that's we're going to look at in
this video now first off the big reason
is price you can get one of these for
refurbished on Amazon I'll leave the
link below and there are a lot of
reviews of people that just got one and
they are very happy but the MacBook Air
you can get for 12.50 at the base model
here the specs side by side and the
Intel used to cost twenty four hundred
dollars compared to 16.99 and I actually
use this one for about a year and a half
and then I sat on my shelf for a couple
years and it works perfectly fine now
what I'm curious about how do the
speakers in the webcam compare what
about performance and what about battery
life size wise they are similar and even
the bezels on the sides are practically
ident identical of course the air has
that Notch whereas the Intel MacBook has
a thicker top bezel to hide the webcam
the old Mac has a 720p webcam and
looking at it it looks pretty dang bad
and this is the 1080p webcam on the
15-inch MacBook Air let me know what you
guys think about how it looks and how
the microphone quality Compares in the
comments below now as far as weight the
Intel MacBook is definitely a lot
heavier it's about a pound but in the
hand it feels more than that it's also
because of the 15 inch MacBook Air is
thinner than the Intel version and I
love how thin and light this thing is
now as far as ports both of them have
two Thunderbolt ports on the left hand
side but on the right hand side the ear
lacks the other two Thunderbolt ports
they just have headphone Jacks and so
you do get a lot more ports with the
Intel version now the air does have Max
save charging which is really nice it
pops in and as far as charging this
Intel one takes forever took an hour and
a half to get to 50 percent compared to
just 30 minutes and then the total
charge is half the time now what is
crazy is inside of this Intel you have a
hundred watt hour battery compared to 66
and even so the air will get two to
three times the battery life this Intel
literally die in two hours if you push
it heavily compared to six and then for
light tasks you can get 15 hours out of
this compared to about 7.5 so if you
care about battery life don't get the
Intel now the crazy thing is even though
this has a new magic keyboard This Intel
one which brought back the magic
keyboard actually has more travel it
feels just as good if not slightly
better the track pads are both very
large and one thing you'll notice is
that this has the touch bar that a lot
of people people hate it now it does
have the Escape key that is split on the
side this was an updated version and I
was never a huge hater of the touch bar
but I definitely still prefer having
regular buttons now one interesting
thing is that the displays are
practically identical in terms of
contrast colors
sharpness the HDR video that you guys
are looking at let me know if you guys
see any differences DCI P3 color
accuracy and even the brightness is
identical but what is crazy is that the
Intel Mac can support four displays
compared to just one on the new 15 inch
and you can actually do two 6ks or four
four case with this thing that is a lot
better even four years older now you'll
notice that the 15 inch air does not
have those speaker grilles that the
Intel MacBook has but it does have six
speakers built in just like the Intel
version so I'm curious how will the
speakers compare let's go ahead and take
a listen
[Music]
thank you
you guys heard it for yourselves the
Intel Mac sounds louder has better bass
better mids so now we know why people
are still buying this thing now of
course this thing is a pound lighter the
air does have the speaker grilles it's a
lot thinner so it's good for its size
but it's still not as good and now we
are going to get into performance how
will these stack up running black magix
SSD speed test we already see that the
air is faster both in right and read
speeds but the crazy thing is if you get
the 256 gig that thing is half the speed
about a thousand megabytes slower both
for read and write compared to this
Intel which costs less when you're
buying it that is crazy into that 2023
now let's run the latest geekbench 6.1
and both of these have 16 gigs of RAM
the Intel does have more performance
cores it has six plus six more threads
and look at that guys as far as a single
core score we have a difference of 82
percent in a multi-core 73 so not double
but looking at the numbers it is close
to that that is crazy but what about
graphics performance we have the last
AMD Graphics that were in these machines
the 5300m compared to a 10 core M2 the
air finished this test in two minutes
this has been going on for four minutes
and it's only 25 done and here we go the
M2 air is 47
more powerful for compute tasks but of
course that is performance and
applications for different stuff A lot
of people are going to be just web
browsing so let's use speedometer 2.0
and see see what the speed is for that
and oh my goodness guys look at this 138
compared to 437 that's over three times
the web browsing performance and let me
tell you what just using this Intel
machine in Mac OS and for websites it
feels a lot slower than the 15 inch air
but what about tougher web-based
applications here I have figma opened
and this is a project by 500 designs one
of the best design studios in California
and with a 15 inch everything is super
smooth I can zoom in here and see how
long it takes to load this up
very very fast high resolution images
let's try with this one even scrolling
down you guys see there's some
stuttering there's some delay let's zoom
in here
waiting
waiting there you go so you guys could
see it is not as good not even close and
now I selected 12 high resolution layers
and we are going to export these and see
how long it takes and that took four
minutes and eight seconds compared to a
minute and 48 more than twice as long
with the old Intel version so you guys
could see the performance even for web
tasks is not even close and what about
photo editing in the latest version of
Lightroom that uses graphics for
acceleration well one thing in the
settings the M2 air has full graphic
acceleration whereas the Intel one says
limited and even in custom it will not
let me change that now the app loaded
three times quicker on the air and
switching between these images here
oh gosh now these are high resolution
raws fully edited so everything has to
be done in real time when switching
through
definitely a lot slower
on the Intel model and now let's export
50 of these images I'm really curious to
see what we're going to get in terms of
difference and the MacBook Air heats up
really fast and it gets really hot
because it is fanless and it does
actually throttle and slows itself down
because of that especially in Lightroom
where your CP and GP are both being
pushed to the limits but the Intel one
even though they have a bad wrap well it
is staying fairly cool with those dual
fans oh my goodness guys we have a
massive difference here the air took a
minute and seven seconds to export this
even though it does throttle whereas the
Intel it took four minutes and 10
seconds yes pretty much four times
longer for the same task and that's
because not only do you have the raw
performance difference but Apple silicon
is also very efficient with their memory
design the unit memory the other
improvements that is insane and lastly
video editing with Final Cut let me mute
this right here now both these can play
back the standard 4K hebc footage now if
you start going into tougher tasks 10
bit hebc the air will have no problem
but this Intel will now just to make
this quick I'm going to go ahead and
Export this five minute project that has
let's apply to film grain and the
MacBook Air is taking the leader right
from the start and I don't know if you
guys can hear that but the fans are
spinning up now on the Mac right here
4200 3900 they're going up higher on the
Intel based Mac even though our CPU and
GP are only about half use because this
does have encoders built in not as good
as the air but they are there and in
this case the air stayed at around 60
degrees Celsius because of their really
good encoders it doesn't even get hot
and that took 2 minutes and 20 seconds
compared to 3 minutes
on the Intel based Mac now doing other
things even opening this up takes three
four times longer the program's a lot
more stuttery
um doing like stabilization instead of
about eight seconds it takes about 25 so
there is a massive difference in actual
usability so you guys let me know what
you think why are people still buying
the uh Intel based MacBooks of course
the price is lower and I I think that's
why people are doing that but personally
I would say if you need to buy one I
would spend a little bit more money get
yourself one of these at a discount
using the links below it is a much nicer
machine overall even though in some ways
the Intel version does be out the new
Apple silicon based version let me know
your thoughts down in the comment
section go ahead and click that Circle
above to subscribe and check out one of
those videos right over there this has
been Max and I'll see you in the next
one
thank you